j'ai appris un truc avec mon premier
mariage parce qu'un mariage réussi ça se
travaille pas ça devrait pas
ça doit pas être qu'une corvée ça doit
rester quelque chose qu'on attend avec
impatience
j'ai croisé un type que j'avais pas vu
depuis lisser genre connu n'importe où
c'est incroyable
[Musique]
j'aurais peut-être une vie très
différente pourquoi tu as envie d'avoir
une vie différente
qu'est-ce qui se passe je sais pas
pourquoi je t'appelle
tout à l'heure je t'ai entendu
je suis en train de faire pourquoi je
pensais tout le tour
qui te considère comme un trésor
je croyais oui mais je sais plus
qu'est-ce que tu es en train de faire je
culpabilise c'est à toi j'ai essayé de
m'a persuader que c'est juste une
aventure que j'aime toujours Jean
tu es toujours sûr qu'il n'y a rien de
suspect
je commence à m'inquiéter là
j'espère que tu es pas en train de
sous-entendre ce que je crains
d'être bien sûr de vouloir savoir la
vérité
bien sûr